c'est le moment de jeter un coup d'oeil
à ces événements qui sont restés dans
l'ombre cette semaine avec mes deux
collaboratrices Fanny olivier est
infectatrice parlementaire à notre
bureau d'Ottawa et Maryline est absente
cette semaine c'est Véronique prince qui
est avec nous à Québec elle est
correspondante parlementaire bonjour à
vous deux bonjour Véronique je commence
avec vous les députés de la claque
étaient à peine à s'ammenter cette
semaine que déjà il y en avait certains
qui avaient des manifestants devant leur
bureau pour leur rappeler qu'il y a des
négociations importantes qui s'en
viennent à Québec c'était un accueil
alors bureau de côté vous allez voir sur
les images ils étaient peu nombreux
quand même les syndiqué mais c'était
pour envoyer un message presque pour
leur dire qu'on les attend avec une
brique infernale mais en même temps on
va laisser le temps à la négociation de
se faire en fait vous avez peut-être
l'impression que ça revient vite
justement des manifestations pour faire
entendre au députés que des négociations
avec les employés de l'État s'en
viennent c'est vrai que ça revient vite
parce que la dernière convention
collective avait été signée il y a trois
ans seulement et on se rappelle que ça
avait pas été facile il y avait eu des
grèves rotatives il y avait des
manifestations le gouvernement avait
décidé d'y aller de façon sectorielle
alors ça aussi ça avait quand même dire
de la frustration lors de la part de
certains syndiqués qui sont habitués de
négocier vraiment en bloc alors cette
fois-ci ce qu'ils disent au gouvernement
c'est n'oubliez pas que nous on va vous
faire part de nos attentes dans le coin
de Noël et que les négociations
commencent officiellement au printemps
alors préparez-vous on va être prêt à
manifester s'il le faut écouter bien le
président de la CSQ Éric jingle
le gouvernement le vu il a fallu en
période de pandémie est en mesure de
trouver des façons d'amener des gens
mais là ça c'est pas fini là les
services publics ne vont pas mieux au
contraire problème de pénurie et là
maintenant il faut parler des conditions
de travail puis ça ça passe aussi par
les salaires
et je vous rappelle que celle qui est au
Conseil du Trésor c'est encore Sonia
label elle a été reconduite dans ses
fonctions et elle aura un mandat quand
même spécial c'est à dire de faire en
sorte que l'État soit
[Musique]
eriduel appelé seul de dégraissage de
l'État Sonia le bel appel repos ça comme
ça l'homme mais elle veut alléger
effectivement l'état public et un petit
rappel amical d'apport des syndiqués
c'est toujours utile il fallait pendant
ce temps-là vous il y a les libéraux
cette semaine qui se sont saisis d'un
dossier qui normalement est l'apanage
d'une [ __ ] ou du Bloc québécois oui c'est
le ministre du Travail chimiste Reagan
qui a lancé des consultations on veut
décrire un projet de loi pour interdire
le recours aux travailleurs de
remplacement dans les cas de conflits de
travail pour les entreprises ou
juridictions fédérales alors on se donne
du temps Daniel on se donne presque un
an pour écrire cette loi vous savez le
recours au briseur de grève s'est
interdit au Québec c'est interdit en
Colombie-Britannique mais ce n'est pas
le cas pour les entreprises sous
juridiction fédérale à leur pensée aux
de penser aux transports interprovincial
et international ou encore aux
télécommunications donc on veut empêcher
les entreprises d'embaucher des
travailleurs de remplacement en cas de
conflit de travail pourquoi et bien
parce que ça enlève du pouvoir de
négociation au travailleur et ça
prolonge souvent aussi la durée des
conflits de travail les libéraux faut le
savoir avaient promis aux dernières
élections un projet de loi dans ce sens
mais seulement pour les cas de leur code
alors avec l'entendre qu'on a signé avec
le NPD on élargit et on inclut également
les codes de grève c'est pour ça qu'on a
pu voir Alexandre Boulouris du NPD aux
côtés du ministre du Travail chimister
week-end dans son point de très cette
semaine fait intéressant Daniel
lelibéraux avait voté contre le projet
de loi anti-briseur de grève du NPD en
2016 alors qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis
le ministre explique que selon lui c'est
la situation du marché du travail qui a
changé les bloquistes eux n'ont pas
manqué de rappeler qu'ils avaient déposé
pas moins de 11 projet une loi depuis
leur création spécifiquement pour
interdire le recours au briseur de grève
évidemment aucun de ces aucune de ces
initiatives n'avait réussi c'est certain
que ça n'a rien à voir avec le
gouvernement minoritable latente et au
démocratique certains comme par hasard
par hasard Fanny Ottawa Véronique à
Québec merci à vous deux au revoir